this is this is tough you know uh our
free speech protections what do you
describe
is a really good really good argument
like who would write about weinstein the
guy's got you know so much money he's
gonna bury you in legal fees
and because of our laws people were able
to write the stuff right but at the same
time
they were what what about not wealthy
public figures
whose lives and businesses are destroyed
so i think about
like uh how this pertains to section 230
and these big tech companies
notably remember that you know it was
the uh
i'll just call the the the poopy men in
media list because i'm gonna try to
avoid swearing but you know what i'm
talking about yep but those that are
familiar
there was a there was a list that was
put together where people just put
random accusations on it of like men who
you know were engaged in assault or
impropriety and it resulted in some
people having their lives completely
destroyed
there was one dude who was innocent
falsely accused
and he like wrote this article and it
was really weird and he said the reason
why his story is fake is because he had
a very
strange sexuality or something that
didn't make sense based on what they'd
accused them of and it was just someone
who was vindictive and hated him
he lost his job nobody would hire him
because they knew he was on the list and
then now he works like a theater as like
a theater manager or something
ridiculous but that woman is being sue
the woman who uh created
who put the who made the list and then i
think other people added to it she's
being sued and it's a very interesting
case
it is it is yeah it's been going on for
a while though yeah this the section 236
is very interesting on this front
yeah well so here's the challenge what
happens if someone tweets
you know uh it's like what was it wasn't
like a google doc the win tweeted or
something
the the list yeah it was a google doc
yeah yeah
so a bunch of but it was not meant to be
made public it was a private google doc
right then somebody else made it public
so that might matter too
i don't i actually don't think that
matters no in defamation private
defamation is the same so
like if if you and i are having a
conversation about you know
john smith and you're like oh yeah you
know john smith he's a guy i might work
with him and i'm like no no that guy's a
nazi and then you're like whoa
well right it has to have caused
material harm so this is presumably it
doesn't if it's just a private
conversation but
this is this this is the challenge
because when
you get these you know far-off
individuals who engage in these
smear tactics against say something like
andy know where they just they know
they're lying
and they completely falsely frame or
push things out of context it is
it is very different to an individual in
the real world saying something
technology has created a completely
different atmosphere
where you can you can literally destroy
someone and then argue
i'm but a snowflake in the avalanche i i
only said my opinion
but when you you so so how do you stop
this
if twitter if twitter knows something is
is overtly wrong or false
like it's a serious challenge you know
i'm for free speech
right you know well should that i mean
this we're having this conversation
right now
i mean twitter is right now twitter is
the more
aggressively biased um social media
platform to my mind
i think facebook is worse now i don't
think that i i think
uh mark zuckerberg has i mean the things
he his stated commitment to free speech
is much stronger
than jack dorsey's definitely the things
he said at the committee meetings
uh facebook has been stronger on saying
we're really not going to try to fact
check ads their ads sorry
um i i think facebook to a greater
degree has said we're gonna i mean
they're still gonna they still do some
policing of
of of uh or plenty of policing of
misinformation to some degree but i
think in a less heavy-handed or biased
way
i mean facebook is so good this is why i
get upset with conservatives who want to
get rid of section 230.
facebook has been um such a powerful
platform
for conservatives definitely breitbart
uh
daily wire ben shapiro dan bongino their
views
on facebook dwarf mainstream media so if
you were going to
uh uh tinker with facebook's liability
for what appears on its
platform i mean good so the media wants
like joe biden and elizabeth warren to
support getting rid of section 230 right
because they're smart people on some
level
and they realize that conservatives can
succeed in an alternate media
environment
whereas like the new york times isn't
even going to ever print a republican
senator's opinion again
so yeah let's go back to that world why
would why do
why do like people like josh hawley want
that like it's insane well i think
i i think that is a mistake but i think
we need 230 reform
i think if i was to ma yeah if i if it
could be
tweaked in a way to i think probably
protect
privacy of non-public people especially
maybe their videos or something
i might be on board with that but i'm
just so i'm so worried that any attempt
to change it will just result in it
being done away with
but the problem is uh on twitter for
example
they will ban conservatives for saying
learn to code
like that's it's clearly not within the
scope of 230.
so well it's not not no they can do
whatever they can do whatever they want
the good faith provision of 230 says
objectionable content
are you going to argue in court that
banning someone for saying hashtag learn
to code is
is would a reasonable reasonable person
believe that it's objectionable
or that lewd and lascivious violent or
graphic no of course not
230 just says they can do right good
faith moderation
of objectionable content so this is a
conversation that we've had on the show
quite a bit is
you know one thing trump's tried to do
is define what
good faith is what objectionable is
because twitter's certainly not engaged
in good faith i think i think if you
presented the evidence to a reasonable
jury they'd say that's definitely not
good faith
you know somebody uh like zubi for
instance okay dude
he tweeted okay dude at somebody who he
didn't know was trans and he got
suspended for it
that's not good faith well the issue
with the suspensions though is they're
all complaint driven
so it ends up looking biased and the
maybe the impact is biased oh yeah
but it's because there's more lefty
people complaining absolutely so
people always say why is this up when
this or why is this taken down when this
is up
you can do that add infinitive on
youtube you can do that with a trill and
there's so much content
and the answer is always someone
complained about that if someone didn't
complain about that
it's what do you do it's because the
left is organized right and because
they'll say hey everybody go flag this
tweet and get taken back
i don't know how the the the social
media platform can solve that problem i
don't know how they could
or if they should be held accountable
that's just that's that's gonna be the
nature with so much content
not enough you can't police it on the
front end or any of you required people
to approve it before it appears
that's the end of the whole game so i
don't know what to do you have
content being so uh there's a lot of
problems with facebook and facebook i
think absolutely crossed the line
with uh i think facebook's in direct
violation of 230 by appointing fact
checkers
right off the bat why so i like that but
this is i like their you're talking
about that council
i think that council which includes some
like some
there's a free speech scholar of cato
there's some people who seem to
to have no no not that oh i'm talking
about how there is a
special editorial group on facebook
where you go through the pointer it was
a pointer institute
you get certified and then your
organization can determine
whether things are true or false those
are the fact checkers right but they
also have they gave didn't they give the
daily caller fact checker status as well
yeah
but it doesn't mean anything uh it
doesn't matter if if there's a
conservative or two it matters that
they have a special class of people who
can flag my content
as false so i had i had a post i made
about bill clinton
um and and uh the woman who you know i
did him on the island
in the court documents that went out my
tweet was 100
factually true and an a fetching
organization put a
a a block over it saying it was false
information
well that's a statement of fact that my
post is false when it was in fact true
and they knew it was true because the
dude told me on the phone he knew it was
true so now we're talking about
we're talking about actual malice when
you link to the guys
so it says false information here's why
when you click it it sends you to his
website where he makes
money i'm assuming off of ads so by
putting
fake fact checks on my content he can
make people click his link to his
website
and get cash of it even though he knows
what i posted was true that's a special
class of people
that is not a regular person that would
be like the new york times hiring a fact
checker to go in
and change posts and link to other
content
that's completely editorial and that's
facebook
so listen that seems like a bad idea or
something they should not do but it
seems like the solution is to complain
about it until they stop doing it
facebook facebook told me right off the
bat i emailed their politics person they
said we will not
intervene in any way they said they have
the right to do so
and so so my question now is this is a
really interesting was their company
right i mean they can do what they want
at the end of the day not not if they're
stealing the commons i completely
disagree with that
so private company they own it so if a
private
company puts up fences around town
square and puts armed guards around it's
not town square it's their property it's
their town square they may act like it's
the town square but
i mean at the end of the day it's theirs
the oh the best way to
to you can complain about their rules
but it's a free product they give you
see this is this i think this is where
we have a strong disagreement
if they've taken over the commons
commons due to
technological advancement then we have a
duty to regulate that to protect the
public
there's no way it's a monopoly it's not
it's a free product
it's there's i don't believe it has
staying if it
if it makes enough people mad enough
people are dissatisfied with it a rival
could easily come around
twitter is to some degree these other
companies are to some degree and you
know what's happened
well the other i remember myspace being
a big thing it's gone now
and what happens parlor could come along
and what happens when and you know what
they did to minds
am i nds.com there was a block on it
facebook wouldn't let you link to the
website
you'd get a warning saying nope you
can't go there if you're going there
from facebook
facebook made it so that if you ever
tried i think they've removed it since
then but google and facebook for a while
blocked the url to um to mine's google
is a more
compelling monopoly case to my mind than
facebook it's just
well it's not so much an argument
argument about uh monopoly because
what service does facebook provide is a
bigger question connecting you to loved
ones
then if that's the case then they do
have a monopoly and if they're
restricting what you can say
and they've taken over the communication
lines between you and your parents
because you don't call them anymore
because you just talk to them on
facebook messenger
then they're starting to take take away
from the public
space well that's like saying giant has
a monopoly on groceries because i'm too
lazy to walk
two more blocks to trader joe's or
trader joe's got shut down because
facebook moved in
dropped the prices to a ridiculous
degree because they can just not require
to advertise for trader joe's in the
giant
so so so here's the issue if it's their
building
so facebook could ban you and your
ideology outright you
your your ideas everything would cease
to exist
in a generation within facebook and i
mean
and where's the thought from other
people no you're too
this is where we just you are too online
you're only it's only that like there's
so many other places conversations are
happening
also i wouldn't i wouldn't be happy that
they i would complain
vociferously where are people getting
started where are they getting their
news from
where are people getting their news from
not just facebook the younger generation
it's almost exclusively social media and
it's predominantly facebook twitter and
youtube
so youtube is a video hub facebook is
specifically an interactivity between
you and people you've chosen to form a
network with and twitter is
is mostly people following high profile
individuals
so these are not it's hard to quantify
what each space does but facebook
definitely has seized a large portion of
the commons
and on these platforms alternate ideas
are thriving
like they never have before and like
they never would under the mainstream
media paradigm absolutely
absolutely but we have to make sure we
maintain that
otherwise we create a more disturb
there's big challenges in both
directions
if we absolutely uh limited 230
so so i just to clarify for people who
aren't familiar this is this is the
liability protection for these companies
then you would end up with like porn
sweeping across facebook because porn is
legal content
right and so that's why they have the
good faith moderation provision
but the issue i'm bringing up
specifically there's like harassment on
a level that no one wants to
it would just be right so absolutely and
which they would have to do if you
applied the first amendment in the same
way
i've encountered proposal will
chamberlain wants i don't know if you
know who that is he's
actually he's gonna be tomorrow really
yeah yeah well you should yell at him
about this we've had this debate that's
what he wants he thinks the same first
amendment
it should be it should be nationalized
in the sense that the first amendment
should apply to it well they can't
police any if they can't place anything
they can wait with a westboro baptist
church rules apply right that would be a
very bad idea they absolutely can though
so long as they're so not under will
chamberlain's proposal no they can't
so though for for instance the way the
mon the way minds does it is that
there's effectively two layers there
everyone is allowed to post
but if you cross a certain line then you
get a not safe for work filter that has
to be turned on
but but people can just choose to be
like i want to follow who i want to
follow regardless
you break the rules you go in filter
mode
that's a key easy way to keep people on
the platform while allowing people to
stay in their wallet garden or whatever
the problem with facebook that i bring
up specifically as it pertains to 230
is that facebook is allowing companies
to make money off of defaming me
and that's facebook saying we've elected
this special class of people
we've chosen them specifically to make
statements on behalf of facebook that
regular people can't
that this is false information or not
statements of fact that are
not based on public user bases
i can't go into facebook and put a tag
on your post saying it's fake
facebook appointed people to do that
that is a facebook editorial assignment
that is not predicted under 230. them
that might not be protected under 230
currently
in which case they're in violation of
their liability protections and anybody
should be able to challenge them in that
regard and twitter the same thing
well it's just like in their like they
couldn't put out a 230 wouldn't protect
them from putting out a press release
that that rivaled you so it's the
situation you're describing might be
close enough to that
new york wherever so but then but that
doesn't require 230 reform that because
that would not be that's fine no no
right
i'm just saying facebook's already in
violation maybe they are and i guess
there's probably a longer legal
conversation about whether they are they
aren't
but the way i see it is if the new york
times
is curating content or actually a better
example is like buzzfeed's community
post they used to have
they choose what to post so if someone
writes something and the new york times
says
you know we have a freelance writer
who's been
appointed to post an article the new
york times is responsible for what they
say when they publish that sure
if facebook is saying we have this
select group of 12 people 12
organizations
who can publish tags on posts it's not
like an article or anything
but they literally called me a liar and
it wasn't true and it just drives
traffic from people who want to see my
content
it was it wasn't actually me who posted
a screenshot of one of my tweets from a
different
facebook page people can make money off
this
facebook has empowered people to make
money by accusing other by defaming
other people
facebook has created that class they're
not regular users if you turned on talk
radio or cable news people make money
off of saying untrue things about people
all the time oh yeah definitely it is a
it is a major way for people to make
money just in general
they can be sued depending on what line
they cross in terms of how they
you know what they say and i guess i'd
be more for expanding the protections
for saying things even if things that
are wrong
in that direction rather than like
holding facebook to the same standard or
something because i i think it's i think
it's most cases it's best handled by
calling it out
rather than the to my mind the libel the
lawsuit should be for
areas of unique harm to people who are
not public people
uh perhaps involving publication of like
private or embarrassing stuff
um that that there's where you find
sympathy
from me for like how can we do we need
to tweak the system to more protect
people from
from sites like gawker from what they
did well that's what i
and i don't have the answer but that's
the area where i'm more
i'm more there's some kind of i mean
they're like publication of private
facts is a
could be an element of i think element
of defamation thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe
hit the like button hit the notification
bell and we are also available on all
podcast platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time